Who says a movie's best actors, jokes, or
references have to be put directly in front
of the audience? Whether it's thanks to a
total fluke, a relationship behind the scenes,
or just a joke too good to pass up, an unexpected
or well-hidden cameo can make a good scene
into a great one. But fans have to notice
them first. Here are Screen Rant's 10 Hidden
Movie Cameos You've Never Seen.
Scream
The late Wes Craven helped create the slasher
genre with movies like Nightmare on Elm Street
and The Hills Have Eyes, but when he returned
with the thoroughly modern Scream, he showed
he truly was the master of horror, regardless
of his age. To celebrate, Craven gave himself
a cameo as the school’s janitor, Freddy,
wearing the signature hat and striped shirt
of his other horror icon, Freddy Krueger.
The Man From U.N.C.L.E.
Guy Ritchie set his skills on a 60s era Spy
adventure with this reboot, but relied on
a few of his friends from the modern age to
fill out the cast. But the most incredible
cameo is the appearance of English footballer
David Beckham as a Soviet projectionist, visible
on screen for just a few seconds.
Ant-Man
When Scott Lang is first trying out his Ant-Man
suit, things don't go according to plan, winding
up crashing on top of a parked car. The driver
isn't random, though: but a cameo from formerSaturdayNight
Live cast member Garrett Morris. Who just
happened to be the first person to play Ant-Man
in live action, during a superhero sketch
that took more than a few shots at Ant-Man's
strange abilities.
Ghostbusters
Few actors have a longer filmography than
Ron Jeremy, but most of his roles are of the
adult variety. Still, the actor made himself
a memorable member of the Ghostbusters’
cast, appearing with his unmistakable moustache
as just an average New Yorker looking on as
the containment unit explodes at Ghostbusters
headquarters.
Fellowship of the Ring
Peter Jackson may have cast Bret McKenzie
as one of the elves in his first Lord of the
Rings without giving it much thought. But
once The Flight of the Concords star was spotted
by fans, they exploded online. As a result
of their passion, Jackson found a place for
the unnamed elf to show up in the end if his
trilogy - with lines, this time!
Iron Man
Marvel's first shared universe superhero film
relied on a soundtrack of electric guitar,
which was actually performed by Rage Against
the Machine guitarist Tom Morello. As a thank
you for providing the music behind Tony Stark,
Morello got the honor of being the very first
member of the Ten Rings taken out by Stark's
first crack at an Iron Man suit of armor.
The Hobbit: The Desolation Of Smaug
Late night host Stephen Colbert revealed himself
to be a scholar of J.R.R. Tolkien's Middle-Earth
over the years, which led to an incredible
role in The Hobbit movie trilogy. Few actually
believed that he had been given a part in
Peter Jackson's movie, The Desolation of Smaug,
but he definitely did, hidden behind an eye
patch and ragged clothing amongst the residents
of Lake Town.
X-Men Days of Future Past
This X-Men blockbuster literally rewrote the
franchise's history, with mutants first revealing
themselves to the world in 1973. And director
Bryan Singer was there to capture it, behind
and in front of the lens. The director makes
a cameo doing - what else? - filming the showdown
between Magneto, Mystique and the rest of
the cast in France.
Catch Me if You Can
It's an impossible story to believe, but the
life of con man and professional liar Frank
Abagnale actually did happen the way the movie
showed (for the most part). To make sure,
the real Abagnale was brought onto the film
as a consultant, and even makes an appearance
as the policeman arresting his younger self.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
When Marvel handed the reins of their Captain
America sequel over to the creators of the
TV comedy Community, fans didn't know what
to expect. What they got was an accomplished
action movie... but the Russo Brothers found
room for one fan-favorite cameo. Since Abed
was probably the only Community character
smart enough to earn a job at S.H.I.E.L.D.,
seeing actor Danny Pudi appear in the third
act actually made sense.
Those are just a few of the cameos we've spotted
in some of our favorite movies but which ones
did we miss? Let us know in the comments,
and remember to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one.